hello everyone and welcome to the final
game will be showing from the super
battle rapid and blitz tournament it's a
game from the playoffs 11 Ireland vs.
Eric Eric you know we've mentioned in
the previous video that two of them tied
for first place both of them 20 out of
36 so now they have to battle it out
first they will be playing to rapid
games then to slow rapid games then to
blitz games and then well and Armageddon
if it comes to that so the first game
ended in a draw where Kyra Kane had the
white pieces now Levin has the white
pieces and well let's just see what
happens and also I would like to mention
I'm receiving the feed in newsletter so
if some of you are not receiving the
philia newsletter the exact date for the
2020 candidates tournament has been
selected it's a story it's a March 15th
til April 5th so if any of you you know
can do something with that information
there it is so March 15 till April 5th
it's funny because the previous
newsletter I received said that it was
from March 5th till April 15th they they
had it backwards and I wanted to mention
it in the previous video but I forgot so
it's a good thing I forgot because it
would be incorrect and you know some of
you might have called your boss and said
I'm taking you know two weeks off
because of the candidates tournament and
then the candidates tournament will not
even be happening at that time so you
know all hell could have broken loose
but you know yeah good thing I forgot in
the previous video so remember March
15th till April 5th now getting back to
the game 11 with the white pieces opened
with e4 and it's a very very exciting
line a very old line e5 Knight f3 knight
c6 with Bishop to c4 Bishop to c5 and of
course the Evans gambit was not played
in this game unfortunately it would be
it would be really cool if it was but we
have c3 the Joko piano so Knight to f6
we're d4e captures on d4 and now II five
and here pretty much default is the only
good reply black cast which I'm sorry if
you play this line you always encounter
d5 Bishop to b5 and not night Stewie for
getting the knight out of harm's way we
have characters on d4 attacking
Bishop to b6 and now Knight to c3 with
castles here and here Bishop to e3 you
you could try and prevent the Bishop
from coming to g4 by playing h3 but I
think it was a it was proven in a lot of
games that if h3 then just f6 for
example is very strong the White King is
still in the center you know you don't
want to mess around so Bishop to e3
better to just develop a piece Bishop to
g4 and now h3 which tempo kick the
bishop away with age 5 and now Queen to
c2 unpinning and it's very important to
unpin here if you don't know that it's
okay to unpin here you might miss a move
like Queen to c2 but it obviously it's a
it's a very nice move because if black
decides the mess of White's pawn
structure here it's really not all that
important because white still didn't
castle especially not King sight for
example if well you're not gonna catch
right away first you're gonna eliminate
this guy here and now if the game
continues with captures here then you're
just gonna capture G captures an f3
attack the night tonight moves and now
Queen a5 and the White is doing great
here the knight is attacked twice Ruby
g1 is coming you can push your H pawn
it's gonna be very dangerous for black
especially in the Blitz game so what you
would have to do after Bishop captures
an f3 and Bishop captures here is to
just go all the way there so capture
some G to Ruby g1 now you capture here
and after rook captures energy to
continue playing this game and while you
might be okay here still White has an
open G file well semi open G file you
can just cast the Queen side bring the
outlook over 2 G 1 could be unpleasant
especially for a blaze game so after
Queen c2 of course our Kraken doesn't go
for something like this he captures on
c3 we have be captured and now f6 and
unlike the previous game between Wesley
and Fabi it's okay in this position to
play if sex the White King is still in
the center of course you want to open up
at the center open up this F file for
your rook so f6 perfectly fine here with
each captures Queen captures and now
well now you kinda don't want to allow
this so better back to e2 keeping an eye
on the night here
rook 8 e8 bringing the rook into the
game and finally
on castles and here there there are two
games that reach this position Knights
the a5 is a normal King th it is a no
move but aged six in this position is a
new move so it is as a most sixteen that
we have a completely new game so what do
you play here
rook eighty-one bringing the the rook
inter game it's you also might be
thinking about bringing this rook to e1
maybe the other group can come somewhere
else but really there are no good
squares like beat b1 really not a useful
square d one what's the rule going to do
there so bringing this recover to you
want and this rook might come useful in
in guarding the F file well D F pawn so
Queen to d6 by black and now with ideas
of maybe infiltrating the position with
Queen to a 3 also Bishop to a5 is an
idea so first with Bishop to c1 not
allowing Queen a3 also preparing to move
the bishop and trade some rooks along
the e-file Bishop to a5 and here there
are a lot of tactics in the air you
might well if white isn't carefully
white play something like a 4 or
something then just trade everything
characters captures captures captures
and you eliminate at this point so it's
a it's a free point for black and it
would be a well basically a technical
win for black of course you cannot
capture the rook on e1 is undefended so
this is what Kerrigan has in mind with
this Bishop to a5 move amongst other
things so Queen to d2 seems a bit ugly
you know putting your Queen in front of
the bishop but it does guard de 1 square
so it's not another problem that the
line we've just shown doesn't work so
rook the e4 adding another attacker to
the d4 pawn so here the thread is
captures in just the rook captures and
d4 as you will not be able to capture
back with the C pawn but 1111 has a very
surprising move for for us Bishop to d1
and now he says ok if you wanted the d4
pawn you can have the d4 pawn but you
can't overthink it it's a police game
you don't have a lot of time sorry it's
a rapidly and they do have a bit more
time yeah I don't know why I was saying
it's a blitz game yeah sort of God that
basically it's a rapid game but still
you know you don't
a lot of time in rap it either so Bishop
captures an f3 with Bishop characters on
f3 and now Ruth character Cindy 411
allows this capture and now of course
you cannot capture because you just lose
the Queen here but you have Queen to c2
and now we're word does the route go you
can't go here you can't go here you can
go here you could go here but then
Bishop g4 traps the rook g3 will just
take it or or you will have to give up
the exchange so the other useful square
is c4
this is the only outer square but now
you get Bishop to a3 this is what 11
plays he's inviting Queen captures on a3
to deliver Bishop to b5 check and after
the King moves just pick up the rook and
enjoy this position being up the
exchange so what you can do here and
what is the best move in this position
is actually nice to be for you block
well block the attack on your Queen and
also white cannot capture because the
route captors and c2 so what you can do
here is just move the Queen but you have
to move the Queen summer so for example
black cannot capture on c3 you might
play Queen to b3 but then you face rook
captures on f3 g captures and now just
there should be six threatening Queen to
g3 with check of course the F pawn will
not be able to capture and it's just a
very ugly position for whites to play
might you might play something like this
and then e maybe oh I can just grab a
perpetual after something like King h2
Queen d6 check and for example repeating
this but after Bishop to a3 Kyra can
played Bishop to b4 it's a similar idea
it blocks but with a very well important
difference that the Queen and c2 is not
under attack so here White has the
opportunity to play whatever white wants
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning move for our
onion in this position while I give you
a couple of seconds for for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
it is the only winning move into
position so congratulations to you and
for those who just want to enjoy a show
its Queen to b3
point being that now
too many threats pawn captures Bishop
just loses a piece Bishop captures and
d5 check will pick up the rope and c4 so
it's very hard to defend everything
there is an engine defense here with
rook the d4 but who plays this I mean
it's still winning for white of course
but point is to just close off the D
file and pick up the bishop on a3 and
try to defend this position being down
the exchange which is not terrible I
mean worst worst things happened in
chess but
kurakin played rook captures an f3
instead just eliminating this threat of
Bishop captures on d5 we have Queen
captures on f3 and now he played Bishop
captures an a3 but it doesn't help any
other movies isn't that great for
example if you try something like Luke
f4 prevent Quinta 5 check after rook to
e8 then you just get Bishop characters
than before which wins a piece because
now both of the Queen's are under attack
so once you capture it now you play rook
to e8 check King h7 and Queen to d1 and
okay now you are up the exchange and if
black really wants to save the knight
move the knight back then you go Queen B
one check and now after g6 for example
you go rook F e1 now threatening just to
go to East 6 then there will be threats
against the g6 pawn and there is not
much to do if you move the Queen so the
rookie citizen come with check you can
even capture and b7 then there are ideas
of just sacrificing the Queen for the
night followed by rookie 7 mate it's
just a just a very unpleasant position
so basically after this Queen captures I
have to remove Cara can went for a bunch
of characters on a three you know if if
y doesn't have anything then black is
just winning but of course 11 played
rook to e8 check King to h7 and queen to
five check and it was in this position
that seve a car can resign the game as
there is nothing more to do here if you
move the pawn to block Czech Queen f7 is
mate and if you don't if you play Queen
to g6 blocking then of course I'm sure
you all see the win here it's a rook to
h8 of course you just deflect the King
from from defending the Queen
then you just pick up the Queen and you
are of course completely winning so with
this win in the game two of the rapids
of the playoffs 11 Oregon is this is the
winner of the Super Bass rapid and blitz
part of the Grantchester which is which
is which is great stuff and he
definitely gets closer to reaching
London the London chess classic and I
believe for Kerrigan without winning
this event I don't think his he is close
to entering along with chess classic but
I'm not sure I'm gonna check out the all
of the standings for for London so I
then we're gonna talk about it a bit
more I haven't checked it in a while but
yeah that's the game eleven takes it all
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Randy raveling for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon we're
now gonna go back to the covering the
feat a Grand Prix checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and when I get
back from Germany hopefully you know
starting a vote on our next big saga
because it's not an easy decision so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest every day